let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
well it is a good wednesday afternoon
the former guy announces
that what he's gonna do is file a class
action lawsuit
against facebook and twitter
and even google for youtube and i think
i'm gonna join in on this class action
lawsuit
i think i'm gonna join in with trump uh
because as you noticed i am only
streaming
on twitter and twitch if you're out
there on twitch
we're not streaming on youtube today and
the reason why is because
i have been temporarily suspended from
streaming on youtube or posting there
they suspended me for seven or ten days
i don't know i don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] them they can have their suspension
so i posted a clip and we're not gonna
get too much into the clip and i'm not
gonna replay the clip because
here's what's gonna happen with this
podcast since it's not live on youtube
once i'm off my suspension i'll take the
recorded version and i'll go post it on
youtube
[ __ ] them but i posted a video
a clip of me talking maybe about
mask maybe and
someone didn't like it apparently they
reported it to youtube
all them oh snowflakes out there
going reporting my videos to youtube
and youtube pulled it down so i appealed
i appealed in the court of youtubes and
googles
and they denied my request so i'm on
suspension from youtube
so we are only streaming from twitter
and twitch today live but we're still
live we're still doing it live
[ __ ] them and then after we're done i'll
do the usual i'll post
it up on all the podcast directories
apple podcast
uh spotify google google podcast it'll
all be
there it just won't be live on youtube
and then once
i'm out of youtube jail and i'm i
i break out of youtube jail in a couple
days i'm not sure how many more days i
have left
of um of solitary confinement youtube
now the youtube channel's still there
you can go see all the episodes you can
go see all the videos
besides that one that they pulled down
and i think it's episode 12.
youtube uh pulled down episode 12 i
believe that's the only
band uh podcast episode that we have out
there
is episode 12 i believe
i think that's the episode that is
banned from
youtube but you can go listen to episode
12 if you want to listen to the band
episode you can go listen to it on
on spotify or apple podcast go listen to
it over there
and if you want to listen to the clip
that they banned off youtube just go to
twitter
i know you guys are out there on twitter
i know you're watching right now as we
speak on twitter
and it's on my profile you can go to the
it i
tweeted about it to let everyone know
hey we're not gonna be on youtube
because someone took my video
and thought it was something that it's
not but you know that's okay
but i may join the class action lawsuit
that donald trump has opened
today apparently which i don't even know
if he's actually filed suit has anyone
found out if he's
actually doing it if he's actually
filing suit
this is this is all a grift this isn't
even a real [ __ ] thing it's obvious
it isn't a real thing
number one he comes out in his fake ass
suit
he stands in front of a fake ass
presidential
emblem the the office of
orange deity donald j [ __ ] up trump
he's standing in front of a podium that
has a fake presidential seal on it
he has american flags and people
standing behind him as if he's the
[ __ ] fake president
and he gives this speech which he can't
even get through here here's a uh
let's see let's see i've got a here's a
screenshot of it
i did a i did a little tweet about it
that he doesn't even know what the
[ __ ] first amendment is because he
doesn't know what the [ __ ] first
amendment is he doesn't know
he doesn't know let's go back to that
look at that look at see the seal there
it's not even a really a real
presidential seal that's the one he
[ __ ] made up
that's the one he made up right and then
and
you see that the the it says prevention
he couldn't even say
he couldn't even say preservation he
said prevention
and then stumbled all over himself of
course uh because he is a [ __ ] bag
of course [ __ ] shitbox can't even
read off a goddamn teleprompter
and we're supposed to take him seriously
that he's going to sue facebook
twitter and youtube what the [ __ ] get
you get the [ __ ] out of here not number
one number one that's why he's doing a
class action lawsuit so his
his [ __ ] followers think they can get
in on it
and they'll send him money and he's
already sending out emails apparently
to [ __ ] grift off this thing because
this guy's completely out of [ __ ]
money by now i'd imagine
and he's terrified that he's not gonna
have any kind of [ __ ] money
once the state of new york and the
manhattan d.a uh
closes up the trump organization here
with these criminal charges
this completely [ __ ] obliterates them
i mean
the trump organization is going down
like a fresh cut
tree so since the last podcast now we
knew on the last podcast that they were
going
to uh indict the trump org
and and possibly alan weisselberg and
they did
on thursday last thursday they indicted
alan weisselberg and the trump
organization
this was not a surprise to anybody now
any other president in history
that would become an ex-disgraced
president two-time impeached
and then go on to have the manhattan d.a
not only
not only indict their companies
cfo their chief financial officer for
tax fraud
but then to indict the actual
organization that they own and they've
been running for decades and decades
as a russian money laundering scheme
that would be
the biggest [ __ ] story that ever hit
stories
ever and everyone's like yeah that makes
sense
that makes sense that trump and his
company and his cfo are indicted yeah
that makes that makes perfect sense
why wouldn't that happen they're [ __ ]
criminals
and they're corrupt and everyone knows
that this guy
has been committing tax fraud and real
estate fraud for [ __ ] years
everyone knows that he brags about it
for [ __ ] sake
i pay no taxes that makes me smart
no one who makes the amount of money
that he claims to pay
make pays no taxes that owns a private
company
corporations big huge companies yeah
they they don't pay taxes but
him of course he would pay taxes if he
actually made the money that he says he
makes
but he doesn't he's [ __ ] broke that's
the grift that's the whole [ __ ] fraud
the whole fraud of donald trump is he's
an actual successful business
person that people like
there's a handful of dumb [ __ ] in this
country that actually like this fool
so we're going to talk about a little
more about the trump organization
today and then we're going to talk about
this
facebook twitter suit that he's trying
to file this class action
lawsuit and then we're going to talk
about how he
you know crushes over hitler we'll talk
about that a little bit because you bro
yeah he's probably seen the story
this new book coming out which you know
everyone's
hyping this book but no one needs to go
and buy this book
to know that donald trump is a corrupt
stupid [ __ ]
you don't need i mean i would i guess
buy the book if you want to read the
material
but you really don't need to read the
book to know
that he's a piece of [ __ ] that he's a
[ __ ] knuckle
you really do not need the book to know
that
so we're going to talk about a few of
those things today
on the tony michaels podcast
today but before i start if you guys are
out there watching on video you notice i
have a a nice blue hat it's brand new
it's got the sticker on it
last week i was wearing a red hat when
tom powell jr was on which is a good
episode you guys should go
watch last week's episode it's still on
youtube so far
and it's all on all the directories it's
episode 25
tom powell jr was on and everyone likes
tom powell jr so go go watch that
go watch that but last week i had a red
hat on and i was
uh we're starting a campaign to make red
hats wearable
again but the good news is we're not
just gonna have red we're gonna have
blue too you see the blue [ __ ] hat
so that's kind of different right so if
you want to support the podcast even
though we're not live on youtube
today go subscribe over there on youtube
let's pile them up with subscriptions to
my channel over there
to show them what for so if you're on if
you're listening right now and you're
not subscribed to the youtube channel
after you get done here go over and
subscribe to that [ __ ]
let's pile them up over there and listen
like share subscribe retweet this if
you're watching this right now on
twitter
why aren't you retweeting it why why
retweet it the podcast right now
hit the retweet button if you're
listening
the other thing you can do is if you
want to support the podcast not just by
watching not just by following not just
by subscribing
but if you like the hats if you like the
[ __ ] stickers we got them in the
store
you just go to thetonymichaels.com it's
all there you can find it all
and all the proceeds go to the podcast
here to keep it up and running
on the on the on the interwebs on the
directories
keep the software going all that kind of
good stuff
but let's get back to trump
suing facebook and twitter i really want
to talk about the criminal charges and
the corruption
of the trump organization and alan
weisselberg and how ivanka trump is
probably the next one to be indicted
because of the inauguration committee
all the money they stole over there i
really want to get to that but
god this facebook twitter story
it's so fascinating that this [ __ ]
crybaby [ __ ]
is so butthurt over twitter facebook
and youtube banning him that he had to
go out and he created a blog you
remember his blog
it didn't last very long a couple weeks
he couldn't get anyone to go look at
that [ __ ]
at all like at all he couldn't get
anyone to go look at that [ __ ]
so so he closed it down
and then decided we'll open up a social
media app
he even had his chinless [ __ ] troll
jason miller go help him open this get
her done or get her or get her
get her grabber grit get her about a
[ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ] this
this social media thing is uh patriot
takes has already got some screenshots
on twitter
a good shout out to patriot takes
because he he's gonna keep us abreast of
this i know
of what's going on over there get her
get her done i don't know i don't know
if that's what it is or not
did has anyone figured out why they they
did get her
g-e-t-t-r why did they do that
i don't i i can't figure that out yet
but but anyways
i i i would surmise that this thing is
going to last just about as long as his
blog last
now is would be my guess apparently the
platform [ __ ] sucks just like
anything else trump does
it [ __ ] sucks it's second class
second-rate [ __ ]
but it's not going so well over there i
don't think and the reason why it's not
going well
so well over there is because he's
hacking sue facebook and twitter to get
his social media accounts back
i mean why else would you i mean other
than the grift
because that that's probably you know
secondary to everything else the main
thing is to grift his supporters
into believing that they're gonna join
him in some [ __ ] class action lawsuit
that's gonna take down
facebook and take down twitter and take
down google they're gonna take him down
he couldn't even beat sleepy joe biden
what makes you [ __ ] idiots think
sleepy
sleepy joe biden who was hiding in his
basement you remember this
do you remember this last year covered
was happening
joe biden was in his in his bunker in
his basement
sleeping remember and the old man
couldn't even conjure up two words
and he beat donald trump by 8 million
[ __ ] votes
you can't even beat sleepy joe and you
think you're gonna take down
facebook twitter and youtube google
get the [ __ ] out of here get the actual
[ __ ] out of here you don't believe this
[ __ ]
this is all [ __ ] grift that's all
this is
just to get your [ __ ] supporters to
give you a couple hundred bucks
that way you can make it through the
next month or two until you get to the
next grift you know the next one
because there will be a next grift
that's what they should have called his
app
grifter not getter grifter the grifter
app
the grifter app
i mean come on it's a [ __ ] grift
so i don't understand how the hell these
[ __ ] morons could believe
that a twice and twice impeached one
term
lose by eight million votes can't keep a
casino open
can't keep his trump foundation open
can't do any of that
actually is going to sue facebook and
twitter mark zuckerberg
and jack dorsey that's your that's your
[ __ ]
plan to take really to take back control
i i don't understand speaking of mark
zuckerberg
did you guys see did you guys see the
[ __ ] video of this guy over the
fourth of july
did you guys see this [ __ ]
i mean i make some cringy videos i'll
admit it
some cringe ass videos but this guy
this guy is the uh i mean alt ultimate
ultimate it ain't no wonder this guy
didn't get laid in college and he
invented facebook
to shame girls who wouldn't [ __ ] him
look at this here is a screenshot of the
video
it is mark zuckerberg on some kind of i
don't know motorized
surfboard i don't know what the [ __ ]
that is some kind of billionaire thing i
don't know what it is
and he's got the american flag
what the [ __ ] is that speaking of
zuckerberg
aren't these billionaires going to space
soon and never coming back
aren't we doing that are they going to
another planet is that what they're
doing
surely we can send them past the moon
right
these billionaires bezos elon musk
zuckerberg maybe we could put him on one
[ __ ] rocket
just one [ __ ] rocket out of here
[ __ ]
send him the some [ __ ] pluto pluto's
not a planet anymore but
send him to that planet [ __ ] him what
why
why is he on a surfboard with an
american flag
what the i mean all he was missing was
the maga hat
and the trump face and the blue line on
the [ __ ] flag what the [ __ ] was that
anyways sorry i got off track there i
digress though
from the zuckerberg weird ass you guys
gotta go watch it
just go to any social media anywhere
and [ __ ] search
zuckerberg fourth of july and you'll see
this
stupid [ __ ] video and i think it was
set to john denver's music which
that's a shame john denver i don't know
if his estate could shut that [ __ ] down
or what but yeah jesus [ __ ] christ
so so we we have we have zuckerberg
carrying american flags donald trump
pissing on american flags by suing
zuckerberg because let's face it with
this facebook
twitter uh lawsuit whatever you want to
call it this grift really is what it is
they keep claiming the first amendment
he getting his presser today
he kept rambling on and on and on he
couldn't he couldn't really put two
words together he couldn't read out of a
teleprompter
about the first amendment he they really
don't understand what the [ __ ]
the first amendment is in the first
place this case
is not only not only
rather they probably actually file it or
not but if they do file
and it does go in front of a judge a
judge is probably going to slam dunk
this into the trash can
almost [ __ ] immediately and the
reason why is because they're claiming
something about the first amendment
which the first amendment doesn't have
anything to do with a private company
kicking you off their platform
let me give you an instance here let's
go back about five decades
before social media and let's say a
magazine
let's i don't know i don't know what
magazine who gives a [ __ ] let's just say
time or newsweek
and donald trump absolutely wanted to
run
a story and and you know within 180
characters he can't type much over that
and you know he put it all in all caps
but let's say he wanted to tweet out a
story 40 years ago in
in newsweek newsweek does not have to
put that story in their magazine
just because he's donald trump they did
they they still don't they can tell you
to go [ __ ]
off it's our magazine it's
our publication we [ __ ] own it
you can go kick [ __ ] rocks that's the
first amendment baby
it's their first amendment right you
like how the first amendment works
when you have a publication you can tell
people to go [ __ ] off
that's what facebook and twitter is you
dumb [ __ ]
the government is not telling donald
trump or anyone else
that they can't post on twitter or
facebook twitter or facebook
when you signed up for that [ __ ]
there was terms and services
and apparently this [ __ ]
couldn't read terms and services
the same way he can't read a [ __ ]
teleprompter
there are terms and services that you
agree to to stay on their platform
if you break those terms and services
just like i did somehow last week with
youtube
they can suspend you
they can suspend you again and then they
can completely [ __ ] ban you
from their platform it's their magazine
in the last example
newsweek can tell you to [ __ ] off we're
not running your story
we're not publishing your tweets anymore
dumb [ __ ] that's how it works
it's their first amendment right not
yours if you want a first amendment
right
to say anything you want on a social
media platform
go open your own you know maybe call it
grifter or gitter or some [ __ ]
and then go over there and publish your
garbage
for all your [ __ ] q anon maga trump
and evangelical idiots
to to eat
good luck good luck to you good luck
with the lawsuit good luck with the
first amendment thing
have you ever noticed that these q anon
maga trump humping idiots
always clamor about two [ __ ]
amendments
only two the first and the second one
and they have not got
a [ __ ] clue what either one of those
amendments say
not a [ __ ] clue especially the first
one
not to mention how much they miss about
the second one but the first one
they definitely know nothing about and
that's what this is about folks
this is all still this white grievance
[ __ ]
it's all the same in white grievance
[ __ ]
all the same because they they wanted to
cancel
colin kaepernick for practicing his
first amendment right
this olympian this
female olympian who who
turned her back on the american flag
peacefully protesting the national
anthem
they want her canceled they want her
banned forever for life
get her out of here
they they seem they seem to not know
what the first amendment what is what it
says and
how it protects us it protects you from
the government you dumb [ __ ]
it's not that complicated really it
really isn't i know
i know it's hard for you guys to
understand and comprehend ideas
but the first amendment's really simple
it really is
it really is not that difficult to
understand
so let's let's uh let's see there's
another
story going around so here's here's the
trump sues
here's the washington post official
article
uh shoes over uh censoring of
conservatives because that's what
they're worried about their [ __ ]
ideas suck
and they don't want people to not see
their shitty ideas
uh oh so another story going around
before i get to the
the trump hitler thing because i do want
to work my way
to the trump love's hitler story
who does not want to hear about a bunch
of fascist
crushing over here
because we had marjorie taylor green
also
also crushing over hitler the last few
days so we'll talk about that too
so the story apparently the
oh yeah that's it so apparently the uh
president of haiti was assassinated
killed something
and of course the right-wing queue and
honors just
went off the rails and they think
hillary clinton and bill clinton
had this person executed or assassinated
because
i don't know of her emails or some [ __ ]
you know all the emails that we didn't
find or
who the [ __ ] knows but uh
so i tweeted out hillary clinton and her
company are under a criminal
investigation in new york the clinton
foundation was shuddered because of
fraud
the clinton's family killed over 600 000
americans
and the clintons are claiming election
fraud but won't show
proof look
folks
hillary clinton is a retired grandma
in upstate new york who tweets every
once in a while
to own donald trump that's it
that's it that's it that's it so
she's retired she's a retired grandma in
upstate new york
who by the way had a wonderful political
career by the way
and did a lot of [ __ ] not just for our
country but for women and children
all over our country and the world
significant political figure did did way
more probably in one month than donald
trump could manage to do in
10 years she [ __ ] worked
and she worked on policy that's what she
did
she didn't just grift and lie she worked
on
policy and that's what we really need in
our government is people who work on
policy
that are serious about it not unserious
like you know the entire republican
party right now
but they're blaming they're blaming uh
this assassination on the clintons
you know because they have to focus
cause so i'm sure tonight on tucker
carlson
fox news and oh you're hillary hillary
hillary hillary clinton clinton clinton
clinton clinton clinton clinton clinton
clinton
it's just on and on and on and on and on
she's not indicted her company is not
indicted the clinton foundation
didn't get shut down because they're a
fraud
the trump foundation did the trump
organization is under criminal
indictment
that's what actually happened but you
know
you know so let's get to this trump
hitler story
anybody hear the trump hitler story
who's heard that trump hitler story out
there
and who is [ __ ] surprised by this i'm
not surprised by this
so apparently when they were on their
their uh 100th anniversary of
the second world war ending in france
uh john kelly one of trump's
one of trump's uh uh
white house chiefs of staff
probably one of the ones that reigned
him in the most i don't know
i guess we'll find that with uh with
time and if you want to know that maybe
you should read the book
but anyways in this book it says
i guess i guess donald trump
surmised that adolf hitler did a lot of
good things
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
listen you there's two there's a lot of
things you do not put in the same
sentence
you don't you just you don't put like
certain phrases and certain words in the
same sentence
and adolf hitler and did good things
do not go in the same [ __ ] sentence
not the same paragraph really not even
the same [ __ ] book
all right they do not go together you
don't put those [ __ ]
two things because there's only one good
thing only one
good thing that hitler probably did and
that's put a bullet in his head
that's it that's probably the only good
thing that he ever did
now but who is surprised
that the guy who stood at the grave of
john kelly's son
who's who called soldiers suckers and
losers
who is [ __ ] surprised that donald
trump
said that adolf hitler did good things
of course we're not surprised by it who
the [ __ ] is surprised by
that he is an outright fascist that's
what's happening
that is what's happening in our country
is he is giving
fascist permission
to be out in front i mean jesus christ
tucker carlson we're surmising
that school teachers elementary school
teachers need to wear body cams
so that we can make sure that they're
not teaching our kids critical race
theory
what they know that critical race theory
is a college course right
that it's college curriculum right they
know that by now
surely over the last three weeks of
people actually
saying hey critical race theory thing is
not what you say it is
it's actually college curriculum it's
not elementary school curriculum it's
not middle school
it's not high school curriculum it is
college curriculum that's what that is
surely surely they got a [ __ ] clue no
no no they didn't because tucker carlson
last night is talking on fox news
about how school teachers should be
wearing body cams so we can make sure
that they're not teaching critical race
theory
they're definitely not for uh law
enforcement officers wearing body cam so
we can make sure that they're killing
that they're not killing black people
and people of color
but we definitely want our elementary
school
teachers to wear them to make sure
they're not teaching little white kids
that racism does exist because we don't
want them to know that
what would happen to our society if
everyone knew the truth
what they mean is what would happen to
our ideas and our [ __ ]
if everyone knew the truth even had mike
pompeo
talking about how we shouldn't know that
the founding fathers were [ __ ] slave
owners
what so if we if we
if we learn in this country
that the founding fathers
were slave owners they were slave owners
that if we know that if we know that
fact by god it could damage our
democracy
if we knew the truth if we know the
truth it could damage our democracy
this is where we're at folks they they
are so [ __ ] steeped in fascism
that they are telling people hey
not only not only do we want to believe
in lies we want to
outright push lies in propaganda hello
we want to push lies and propaganda
because we shouldn't know that our
founding fathers
were slave owners because that would be
the truth and it would damage our demise
what the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
mike pompeo you fascist sack of [ __ ]
so we have tucker carlson saying school
children should be
filmed because that's what he wants
is he wants the teachers to wear body
cams to film the students learning
you know that right that's that's it's
not the the camera doesn't point towards
the teacher
the camera points towards the students
he wants to watch the students it's
[ __ ] weird it's [ __ ] weird tucker
carlson
it's [ __ ] weird
you [ __ ] creep so he wants to
watch the children and what they're
learning mike pompeo does not want our
children learning
that the founding fathers were slave
owners i guess
because by god if they knew the truth
they might just
you use their brains a little bit and
understand the history of our country or
something i don't know
and then you have marjorie taylor greene
talking about
the holocaust again she is really
obsessed
obsessed obsessed with nazis
and what they are and what they aren't
she has no clue
what nazi germany is and the holocaust
she keeps comparing it to things that
are not the same
joe biden comes out and he says that
they are going to go door-to-door
to try to get people vaccinated that's
he said that
and she compares it to the holocaust
what
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
so let's see what else do we have
we have the trump
[Music]
let's go back to the trump organization
i i'll talk about trump organization
a little bit more since we didn't really
get to it much last week we had tom
powell junior on last week and last week
we we we talked a lot about don jr
we talked a lot about the the trump
organization uh
tom gave a lot of his opinions about uh
what he actually thinks uh trump will do
it that
that trump will go to prison he thought
that trump would go to
prison in new york that new york's gonna
get this guy it's gonna be like a
like a like a john gotti thing and
they're gonna tote
uh donald john gotti trump off to prison
in the state of new york i believe
that's a possibility
i'm not sure exactly what it looks like
when you arrest a former president
i don't know because we've never seen
that before um we know what it looks
like when you arrest and
imprison scumbags like trump we've seen
that
we know how that works i mean you
watched uh paul manafort go to court you
watched roger stone go to court those
[ __ ] scumbags
that's that's kind of what it'll look
like with donald trump
that's what it'll look like i think now
apparently the news is uh since last
thursday when alan weiselberg and the
trump organization
were indicted on uh tax fraud
tax scheme uh fringe benefits you know
they keep gay on and on and on and then
his rally this weekend
he kept talking about the company cars
and
and fringe benefits as as if as if he
doesn't know that you have to pay taxes
on all that and evading taxes is not
only a state crime it's a federal crime
too
when you're intentionally evading taxes
and and they got two sets of books to
prove this
they got two sets of books the
prosecutors do
that's not good that's why they indicted
the cfo
and the organization itself
but but the the word is some of the
reports are that ivanka trump
is the next target of the manhattan da's
probe
um i actually talked about this i think
last week or the week before
about ivanka and weisselberg and why i
think ivanka
is probably a very very very big target
in the probe of the manhattan d.a
and the reason why is because ivanka
trump
was involved very closely with alan
weisenberg in the scheme to
rob the inauguration money
there are millions and billions and
millions of dollars that has just went
poof gone
and ivanka trump and alan weisselberg
were kind of in charge of that so that
money went somewhere and because it went
somewhere
well
somebody stole it and if you remember
there was a uh big time donor that was
involved in the inauguration committee
that trump actually pardoned
he pardoned that person there's all
these little things that lead back
to this and that which
when you're talking about the
inauguration committee and the money
stolen there
and it's very unclear to me exactly if
they use the trump organization to steal
that money or how they did this but uh
i think that's why ivanka trump is the
next target in the probe for the
manhattan d.a
i think there's going to be federal
referrals i think that's how they're
going to get alan weiselberg and ivanka
to flip
is using the federal prosecutors the
federal courts
and the manhattan d.a was very smart to
get those
tax returns from the trump organization
and trump himself
to find out what was in those things to
figure out
the scheme of how they stole this money
there's also the rudy giuliani case that
is not going well
for rudy apparently rudy has been
bothering the [ __ ] out of trump to get
his money for the legal fees for all the
election fraud garbage
and trump has been ghosting him i did a
little tick tock on it
let's listen let's listen to the tick
tock and then we'll talk about
the rudy case and the joel greenberg
case and ukraine
and maybe even this manhattan da stuff
on the other side i'll jg wentworth if
you need cash now let's talk
apple party mcshardy rudy giuliani is
having a little trouble getting his
legal invoices paid
i guess this [ __ ] box is running out of
money for his own criminal defense
get the whole big lie thing but how
could you idiots be so [ __ ] stupid
that you would think trump would
actually pay you
grandpa farty mcsharty and grandpa
poopypants are breaking up
who's going to defend the former guy
maybe call sidney powell and lynn wood
nah they're too busy conjuring up q and
grifting the kraken
i guess now his best option is to
torture a bunch of strangers
into giving him their attorney's
business card in the mar-a-lago wedding
buffet line
i guess trump's america is fresh out of
ambulance chasers jesus [ __ ] christ
this is how it all comes coming down
folks no money
no attorneys the plea deal line is open
tried to tell you dumb [ __ ]
ninga poop nitwits
and you wouldn't listen he's a [ __ ]
fraud
[ __ ] him
so rudy giuliani is having a little
trouble
being ghosted by trump and it's not
surprising that trump was not gonna pay
this [ __ ]
number one rudy giuliani was grifting
trump trying to charge him
massive amounts of [ __ ]
fees for a fraud of
election fraud the big lie as it were
and you thought you you were out
perpetuating this big
lie [ __ ] that was completely false i
mean jesus christ rudy giuliani went
and testified in front of state
legislator and purged himself
because he said the exact opposite
things in the state legislators
that he was saying in federal court when
he had to be in front of a judge which
the the cost of perjury would cost him
his law license which it did
in the state of new york
so now trump's not gonna pay him who
should be [ __ ] surprised by that
no one should be [ __ ] surprised by
this nobody
[ __ ] nobody
but rudy giuliani is in a lot of legal
trouble here with this ukraine thing
and somehow rudy giuliani it keeps
coming back
you hear this joel greenberg case and
apparently joel greenberg has petitioned
to uh prolong
the sentencing hearing for him to be
sentenced
in in his plea deal that he before he
pled guilty to sex
trafficking and the reason why i think
that's significant to the rudy giuliani
the donald trump thing
is because joel greenberg apparently
petitioned giuliani and roger stone
and jared kushner to get them to lobby
and paid them
is the word 250 000 which if he really
did pay
roger stone to to to petition
kushner and giuliani to go lobby the
president of the united states donald
trump at that time
if he really did pay him 250 000 i would
imagine
that goal joel greenberg has that venmo
receipt
he had all the other venmo receipts from
all the other crimes he was committing
with matt gatz
and all the underage prostitutes taking
them across the state lines and state
borders and
paying for drugs and prostitutes all
kinds of [ __ ] on your venmo so surely
he's got that venmo rece
receipt i'm sure joel greenberg that is
but giuliani appears in this case
this is crossover from the ukraine case
so he's he that the probe the fbi probe
that caused the raid
was was the quid pro quo where he was
acting as a foreign agent
and he was using quid pro quo and using
using
what he didn't have authority over which
was
united states aid to ukraine
as a quid pro quo to get the ukrainian
government ukrainian president
in particular to come out make false
public statements about joe biden
because they were scared joe biden was
gonna beat them hmm i wonder why
probably because it sucks to suck that's
why they were scared of joe biden
they [ __ ] suck their ideas [ __ ]
suck they know that we know that their
ideas [ __ ] suck
and they know that we know that they
know that we know that their ideas
[ __ ] suck
and that's why they were terrified of
joe biden
terrified of him because he was going to
stop the [ __ ] out of him
that's why they tried to cheat to win
that's why they keep saying all the
democrats cheated the democrats cheated
oh the election was rigged they tried to
rig the election that they're trying to
rig the next one
with all the voter suppression laws
they're trying to rig the next
[ __ ]
and they're surprised that they didn't
win because they tried to rig it
russia russia are you on line one are
you on line one
we missed you we thought you were gonna
help us in 2020 can you help us in 2022
that's that's why putin didn't want
[ __ ] biden to be the goddamn
president in the first place
putin didn't the actual president that
we had the last four years
you know they love putin
they're putin's puppets
rudy giuliani shows up in the ukraine
case and he shows up in the joel
greenberg case
and it's funny to me and yeah yeah i
just find it hilarious
funny it's kind of odd
that joel greenberg is asking to prolong
his sentencing
now the reason why you prolong your
sentencing is because
you're trying to give as much [ __ ] as
you possibly can to get your federal
prison sentence lowered because joel
greenberg
pleading guilty to the charges he's
pleading guilty to this guy is not going
to go to a cushy federal prison camp
that's not where he's going he is not
going to a federal
prison camp that's not where he's going
he's going to be a chomo he's going to
be a sex offender he was sex
trafficking so he's going to go either
to a
low or a medium or
a specific prison
for sexual predators is where he's going
to go when he's sentenced
which is not a low uh no security prison
they are real [ __ ] prisons he's gonna
serve a real [ __ ] prison sentence in
federal prison
a real one so he is not going
he is going to try everything he can do
to keep that actual prison sentence
lowered so the longer he has to keep
feeding information
to prosecutors to get them on his good
side for his guilty plea
the better off he is in the end in the
sentencing hearing when the magistrate
sentences him and the prosecutors say
well he was very cooperative in all
these cases look at all the evidence
that he gave us
look at all the other prosecutions that
we got roger stone
rudy giuliani jared kushner donald trump
matt gatz because you know matt gatz is
gonna flip too
right this motherfucker's gonna flip too
he showed up at trump's [ __ ] nazi
rally in florida or whatever that thing
was
and he's all soaking wet out in the rain
trying to gain uh favor with donald
trump
and the trump supporters so that way
when he flips they don't think it's him
he's gonna flip he's gonna flip that
that
he that rube is gonna flip he's gonna be
terrified
of federal prison the same way joe
greenberg's terrified of it
that's why joel greenberg flipped it's
because
someone got to joel greenberg and told
him the truth look
if you go to trial and a jury convicts
you of what these charges are
you are completely and utterly [ __ ]
you will go to a
high security federal prison and you
will be branded
as a sexual predator in that prison and
it will not be good for you
it will not be good it's not good
the federal prison camps not so bad
maybe
some people call them cushy you are not
going there
that is not the prison you are going to
like michael cohen and paul manafort and
roger stone if he would have went
to prison they would have went to
federal prison camps joan greenberg is
not going there
matt gatz when he gets charged with sex
trafficking
and he flips and has to plea he's gonna
try to plea
out of any kind of sexual crime so he
can go to a federal prison camp
that's how it's gonna work that's why
matt gatz is gonna flip
when they pull him in to this [ __ ]
probe if he's not already flipping
which that's probably the case that's
probably why matt gatz has not been
charged yet
is because he is flipping he is talking
he is giving receipts
that's probably why and he's probably
backing everything that joel greenberg
says
that's why they're prolonging this
sentencing hearing is so that they can
gather as much [ __ ] on someone else
which if you look at the joel greenberg
mat gat scheme
there's only one way up it's roger stone
getting paid to lobby rudy giuliani who
shows up
in an fbi probe and a raid for the
ukraine deal
and jared kushner on
january 17th people january's go back
and look
go back and [ __ ] look on january 17th
rudy giuliani
ivanka trump and jared kushner went to
the white house
to lobby the orange deity the
the the cheeto mussolini jesus
they lobbied them for pardons that day
i mean i'm just surmising allegedly
they allegedly lobbied him for pardons
well the word is is that joel greenberg
gave roger stone 250 000
to convince giuliani and kushner to go
lobby trump
for a pardon of all the crimes he has
now pled guilty to
which joel greenberg obviously did not
get a pardon for
or he wouldn't have to plead guilty to
them
i believe that there's a possibility
that mr gatz was on the list for that
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
hmm i guess that could be a possibility
how could it not be a possibility
in this scheme of course this could be a
possibility
in this scheme and and there has to be
someone
if joel greenberg is at the top of this
scheme as he is already pled guilty
there would be no reason for the federal
court to prolong
his sentencing there would be no reason
no reason
absolutely no reason if joel greenberg
is the only one that's going to get
prosecuted in this case
and joel greenberg is the end of the
line the head the head the big fish
as they call it the big fish they would
be sentencing him they would not be
prolonging it
there would be no reason to prolong it
other than
prosecutors joel greenberg
the courts believe that there is a
bigger fish
the grand jury believes that there is a
bigger fish
that somewhere inside this sealed deal
this plea deal the seal plea deal that
they made
because there's a seal plea deal there's
the one that we see and then a seal one
that no one else sees
that only the courts see to protect joe
greenberg
and what he's saying to prosecutors
so in that there's something that's
saying hey there's bigger fish here
bigger fish
matt gatz been mowing a couple times to
joel greenberg
for underage prostitutes allegedly that
using his venmo account publicly which
is kind of stupid but you know
that that that is not bigger fish than
what they charge
joel greenberg with they had like 22
charges against this [ __ ]
that's pretty goddamn big fish if you
want my opinion
but rudy giuliani shows up in this case
rudy shows up in the joel greenberg case
when you talk about 250 000 going up the
ladder to roger stone
rudy giuliani and jared kushner
possibly possibly lobbying the president
at the time donald j
trump for a pardon for joel greenberg
and wouldn't you think matt gatts would
be on that list now i did a video
i did a video on january 17th about rudy
giuliani going to the white house
to petition the orange mussolini jesus
for these pardons now i surmised that it
was only his name on the napkin that he
had
written out for the pardons that he
wanted the list of pardons on a napkin
i surmised that it was only rudy
giuliani's name on that list
but now i'm starting to think that it
was not just rudy giuliani
it had joel greenberg's name uh a lot of
names
possibly matt gatz's name possibly i
don't know
but matt gatz is not the big fish i
don't think roger stone is the big fish
i think that's why roger stone's losing
his goddamn bind
is because he didn't flip on trump the
last time he was in federal trouble
is he gonna flip on him this time i
don't know
i mean if he gets tied up in this joel
greenberg case he may or he may not
but that's what they're searching for
bigger fish bigger fish bigger fish
bigger fish bigger fish
and that's where rudy giuliani and the
federal fbi raid
on his apartment with the ukraine deal
with the with the whole first
impeachment ukraine quid pro quo
he shows up in that federal case he's
going to show up in the joel greenberg
case
and it's all tying together with the
federal indictment
with with the inauguration committee i'm
sure i'm sure that's gonna have a lot to
do with it but rudy giuliani is very
desperate for his legal money his legal
funds
he needs cash now call jg
wentworth if you need cash now i don't
even know if i've got that right it's
been a while since i've seen that
commercial
but i did use that at the beginning of
the video you get it you [ __ ] get it
you get it thanks for watching today
thanks for
thanks for being so patient um
thanks for being so patient with us on
this youtube thing i really do
appreciate it again
just to give you just to give you a low
down youtube did suspend
me for a clip that i posted on youtube
that clip is on twitter it is on tick
tock if you want to go watch it
there you will see the clip that they
suspended me for
but it's only a temporary suspension
like five seven
ten days something like that i'm not
sure exactly what day we get off
suspension out of
out of youtube jail but as soon as we
get out of youtube jail we'll post this
this episode as a video on youtube
but right after we get done uh
broadcasting here which we're
broadcasting live on twitter
and on twitch but as soon as we get done
broadcasting here i am going to go do
what i do every week i'm going to go
post it on all the podcast directories
apple podcast spotify google
it'll be in all those directories so you
can go listen to it there if you don't
want to watch my ugly mug
you can just hear my beautiful voice
it'll be over there
immediately for you to listen to and go
listen to that deleted or that banned
episode from youtube i think it's
episode 12.
go listen to that one comment there tell
me if you think that
uh if there's anything i said wrong in
that one that
the reason why it should be banned and
also go watch the clip that youtube
banned me from on youtube
or or uh on tick tock if you if you like
to watch me on tick tock you can see
that both
i put the clip both those places but
this week
unfortunately we're not live on youtube
but we are live on the internet
but we will post this video i do have
some news that i want to tell you about
for next week
i'm gonna drop this news right here at
the end for everyone who
stayed with me and watched the entire
time so now you'll know before anyone
else
which you're going to know in a few days
anyways next week we have a huge special
guest
huge special guest next week it's
actually a recorded episode because they
couldn't do it live next week
but it's anthony walker the hot medic
from twitter everyone out there on
twitter i'm announcing it right now next
week
anthony walker's joining us on the
podcast
a special guest episode i'm i'm i'm
floating it right now so anthony if
you're out there
if you're out there hot medic retweet
this episode
and i'll probably cut this as a clip so
that he can retweet it again and retweet
it again and retweet it again
and what we're going to do in the next
several days is we're going to give you
a little taste
of what next week's episode is going to
be about and the reason why is because
it's pre-recorded anthony couldn't join
us at the live
time we couldn't do it live but i still
wanted him as a guest
so we had him as a guest so it's going
to be recorded next week so here's
what's going to happen next week
it is not we're not going to have a live
episode on twitter
or twitch we are going to have a
recorded post
of anthony as our guest the hot medic
anthony walker from twitter
we are going to have him as a as a
special guest
and it'll be posting on youtube so check
that out next week that'll be episode 27
with special guest anthony
walker now i'm glad you guys got to join
me this week and i apologize for all the
twitter nuns
are the the youtube nonsense with the
suspension
and being in jail but we'll make bail
soon
we'll make bail soon and we'll appeal it
and maybe
just maybe maybe just maybe we will join
trump in his class action lawsuit to sue
the [ __ ] pants off them
and win because they can't suspend me
you can't suspend me
you can't do it you know why
[ __ ] up you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me